Clinical Decision Support or CDS is
an early and particularly interesting domain within Health Informatics.
Its purpose is to provide clinicians, patients,
and others with knowledge and personalize information,
intelligently filtered or presented at
appropriate times to enhance health and health care.
According to ONC, "CDS tools include
computerized alerts and reminders to care providers and patients, clinical guidelines,
condition-specific order sets, focused patient data reports and summaries,
documentation templates, diagnostic support,
and contextually relevant reference information, among other tools."
We will discuss three key clinical decision support projects to illustrate
how early researchers recognized it as
an opportunity and the challenges to successfully implementing it in practice.
My purpose in placing this discussion here is to set the stage for appreciating how
two key capabilities of FHIR and SMART on FHIR are making clinical decision support,
a far more approachable and clinically-useful tool.
The first is facile retrieval of EHR data in a standard format,
facilitating the integration of FHIR apps into any EHR.
This also obviates the need for any redundant data entry by the provider.
The second is seamless integration into the provider's workflow,
making the use of clinical decision support far more efficient and therefore more likely.
Finally, this discussion will expose you to some of what I consider the most fascinating
parts of the history of Health Informatics and the vision of some of its pioneers.